appreciate it
no worries
but this isn't this isn't live streamed
something
3 30 welcome to everyone to the um
community strategy committee
meeting um obviously we've got a uh
a mixed agenda here this afternoon some
interesting topics to go through and a
lot of
reports and progress on how things are
going so
um just check there's no apologies from
the floor first
guinness phillips
right so um we just take
those apologies are received
past that
second that all in favor
okay um i don't believe there's any
conflict of interest
with any of the topics we're going
through today but if there is they could
be declared now
okay right so our first
agenda item today um is
uh we have welcome to louise from coin
and she's going to um i don't know
whether you want to do any introduction
there as well anne or
whether yeah louise welcome to the
google council
and um here's a powerpoint and obviously
going to go through
progress over the last few years and
what's coming up
i'm lou i'm the chief activator and the
general manager at coin south
in invercargill um queen south is an
innovation network and it used to be an
investment and innovation network which
is why we haven't explained the acronym
coin anywhere in this this document um
i'm going to take you through a little
bit about who we are because i
i think most of gore probably don't know
yet
we've certainly had some amazing
founders come out of gore
recently and the surrounding areas um
so i'd like to share some of those with
you and i also want to share with you
where we're going for the the future a
wee bit and just fire any questions
you've got at me
um so our vision
we want to be the driving uh the engine
driving southland into an innovation
economy it's super important to
diversify
our economy at this stage and
we're already seeing a lot of innovative
new ideas coming through in existing
industries and heritage industries like
farming and engineering but
also in fringe spaces as well which is
super exciting
our mission is to drive measurable
impact as the partner of choice for
founders
and the innovation community so we're
not just talking about entrepreneurship
but also existing innovation
in businesses and new innovation in
existing businesses
is also all across southland so we were
established in
2019 we're almost two years old and
since then uh our team has grown i'll
start with that team sorry this is me
on the left uh nikki a marketing manager
and events manager in the middle and
we've got a community manager friend on
the right hand side
prue haustead was a chief starter and
has recently moved onto the board
of coin south
and the reason we were started in the
first place came out of swords
which i'm sure most of you will be well
aware of
um so we were the innovation arm of
swords
and it was identified pretty early on
that there needed to be so
some diversity in the economy um
so peru is now on the board we've had
sheree from the chamber of commerce
sitting as a gm and now i'm taking up
that mantle uh so sharia is also back on
the board
as strategic partners we've got six po
or pillars of the community that we want
to work with and each of them represent
one of the partners that we have or
we're planning to get
so we work with naitaahu environment
south and community trust
sit the chamber of commerce and
underpinning that we've got a little bit
of callaghan innovation
support as well from the government
we're we're looking further into mb
and we are looking for a council to get
on board
um so
actually let's go back to that we've we
get a little bit of money from all of
our strategic partners
and this is to do with aligning
innovation in all parts
of the community and making sure that
those parts of the community are
driving this innovative change uh
throughout southend as well um
we also have 17 corporate members or
sponsors who
give us a little bit of money too so
that's how we've funded we've had
provincial growth funding too but we're
in a
third year coming up to our third year
and that will end soon as well
so what coin is and what it looks like
is probably the most interesting part
um we work with basically anyone before
covert we worked with specifically
startups that could scale beyond the
region um but we realized very quickly
like most people
in covert that we needed to pivot and
help those
who could thrive um now in this new
normal
so since we've started we've worked with
234 different founders
our youngest is 15 and our oldest
is 82 and they come from all over the
region so right up to lumsden we've got
chris from gathergame we've worked with
quite a bit paige from
i'm going to get the name wrong gleny or
cheese so she makes halloumi out
in balfour zeb harold is from riversdale
and i'm sure you've
seen him pop up quite a bit lyden's from
uh belle clutha ricky's from wynton
rajiro is from racchio
uh nate's from bluff julie's from
taito uh yeah they're all over the show
i've got heaps and invercargill and um
um so basically coin is set into three
parts we've got
founder incubation um
community events and scalable startups
so i'll take you through each of them
quite quickly and then just
fire any questions you've got so make it
matter
this is that founder incubation piece
this is what the founder journey looks
like
so we get calls referrals people walk in
to the office that's located in don
street and invercargill
and they they find us on website or
through social media
with every single person we give them a
lean canvas which is basically
a one-page business plan and get them to
fill it out and we
go through it with them figuring out
next steps who we can connect them to
straight off the bat
and give them pretty comprehensive
guide for what to do from here
every person goes through that and it's
basically a
gatekeeping for how we
put them into the next either programs
or push them through
to existing partnerships like great
south the chamber of commerce
or some of their national incubators so
we work really closely with startup
networks all over the country
um the big ones are sprout so that's the
agritech
accelerator program soda inc in the
waikato they
do seed funding and we push quite a few
people through there if they can't find
their own family friends money
um it's quite a great opportunity they
can get up to 5k through soda
we also have an innovation fund that was
set up by the chamber of commerce
that used to be called the manufacturers
trust so
there's a fund there of adk to help
people
start their prototypes so they can test
things quite often the biggest barrier
for
getting an idea of the ground is that
initial seed
money just to make the prototype to
prove that it works to then get
some some credibility so uh
that big fearless in the middle of that
that picture there that is the
the one page canvas um everyone has to
do that it's
pretty it's a living document that's
pretty simple questions what's your idea
who are you solving it for
why is this why does it matter what are
the trends in the market what are the
barriers stopping you bringing this idea
to life
who are you what skills do you bring to
this and what do you want from us
is it simply a connection do you want
mentoring do you want
money do you want upskilling whatever it
is tell us so that we know who to
connect you with
and from there we place each of the
founders in a particular
program so sell it is very light touch
that's basically a community events and
i'll go over that and wee bit but
it's it's taking any small business
and giving them the skills like
marketing or finances they need to
to keep going um start it is
for a business or an idea that
needs help actually just starting so how
do i write my idea up into an
articulate way how do i pitch it to
somebody
how do i find a distributor how do i
find
a graphic designer anything in the very
very early stages
prove it is all about validation so
that's validating both the
the problem and the idea so am i solving
a real world problem
and am i solving it the right way is
this the best idea and this is a 12-week
course
we've just uh we're in our 11th week of
our of their latest one
proven food and fibre and everyone's a
little bit panicky right now because
i get them to set a goal right at day
one and by 12 weeks
they should have achieved that goal and
they're all bespoke goals
so we've had everything from sales goals
to
marketing goals to prototyping goals all
manner of things
and then nail it is for the really
scalable
businesses and i work i create a bespoke
program for each of them and we only
take on
probably about four a year of those guys
i'd love to to extend that and make it a
lot more than that but
currently building the pipeline is
probably more important in
building that entrepreneurial capital
you can see
beyond the programs there's a popcorn
pitch and fireside chats at the top
that's really light stage
pitching opportunities that's really fun
if you ever get the opportunity to come
perhaps we should run one and go
actually it's where the public gets
pitch any idea for a minute
or a startup course all go through that
as well so it's their opportunity to
share their idea in front of
peers but it does mean that anyone can
stand up and pitch an idea which is
really fun
uh really informal uh yeah it's a good
night fireside chats is when we open up
um
events to allow founders to meet up see
other alumni
founders uh ask really hard questions
and just
um understand more about the journey
on prove it and now that we host a demo
day
in showcases and foundex we've got a
demo day coming up on july the first for
our pruvit
team uh which you're all more than
welcome to come along to it it's
in invercargill and then beyond that
demo day we can
push our founders either to my which is
an angel investment network which i'll
talk about or a national accelerator
program like sprout
so that's basically the whole journey we
work with partners all the way along it
but yeah that kind of gives you an
overview
so in our startup course that's that
really early stage
we've had people like kim on the left
she's
started a earring business through
covert
um and it's made of bike the earrings
are made of bike tires
she's learned about marketing
mostly and started um a little bit of
financial advice in there
and uh growing her network on social
media and how to
to get out to more people camille
is a dancer and so she came in to start
it with an idea to do a
a series of events called sip and dance
and her events will launch i think it's
in two weeks time which is pretty cool
danny's got an amazing
idea um so the biggest thing that danny
got out of starter i think was
confidence
her idea is born from a need
for tech advice for
elderly she works for a tech company in
town
and they charge quite extraordinary fees
uh
in general so she found that there was a
niche
where people just wanted to learn how to
turn their computer on
and how to find the right recipe on the
internet
and how to like really simple things but
there was no one in that market so what
she's doing is connecting grandchildren
with elderly paying grandchildren
the the small amount and she's just
facilitating this and it's
it's a really clever way idea so she
launched that with an
airlift startup course which is really
cool
prove it these are the ones i was
talking to you about are in the 11th
week so we've got
14 different teams 18 founders um
and they're all in the food and fibre
sector they're everything from
a high-end chef who's coming who's just
come back from
london working with michelin star chefs
who wants to start his own
uh space here in southland to uh rt in
the middle there he
works as a cheese maker out in a
telltale with julian roger guys
making paneer and indian cheese
and they've got into homeland in
auckland they've been on rnz though i
think they were actually in stuff
two days ago or today or yesterday you
may have seen them
zeb if you know zip you'll know he's got
hundreds of ideas
so one of my biggest goals for zeb was
to focus him
for 12 weeks and so he's been focusing
this 12 weeks on a
product called ra nutrition and it's a
plant product based on his
polypermaculture paddocks
where he dehydrates all of the leafy
greens and turns them into a powder that
you can
take as a shot kind of like nutri-rescue
if you've ever seen it
what's really cool about this product is
it's traceable he can tell you where the
plants come from what crop they came
from
that sort of thing and it's based on the
the trends that are happening at the
moment i think he could go really far
he's made what he thinks is the world's
biggest solar paneled dehydrator um
and makes the the whole process carbon
negative
which is pretty impressive olivia on the
left is from mesh catering
she's doing marketing pieces uh within
her business so
i just wanted to show that we've got
very varied people coming through these
courses
while they're all in the same sector
they can have completely different goals
um over the 12 weeks and they can still
work together and feed off each other
so basically this this works is set a
goal and then every two weeks come
together and have lunch at coin
i'll bring down a speaker from around
the country um
and they get to quiz them on the
insights of being a startup of being a
business
how to deal with challenging moments in
business
um and the the best thing they they take
away is actually getting to know each
other and bouncing ideas off each other
um the second part of the business out
of these three bring money south this is
that scalable startups piece
uh these are the ones that truly are
going to change the economy and
while we only have a handful now i
imagine this will get bigger and bigger
as the pipeline does
so backlands sorry that type is a little
bit small but
ethan was one of our really early stage
founders he came through um
so he's made the world's lightest bipod
so
the thing that you stick your gun on to
help you shoot straight
as you can tell i know nothing about
guns um
but he came in it is less than the
weight of my iphone
which is pretty impressive and it's
really quiet so if you're stalking a
deer
you can put it into place without making
a clicking noise and
making the deer run off so he has
got online he's got sales into america
and canada
he's doing incredibly well so the
biggest thing that we helped him with in
this one was innovation fund he got a
prototype made
and then turned that into a real product
to then distribute
which was pretty awesome and the piece
that he got prototyped was just the
mechanism
for clicking it onto the gun
yeah this is brian bryan runs innovative
fishing supplies basically he's a
fisher boatman from way back 44 years of
chartering fishing boats
he takes big commercial ideas and turns
them into
recreational fishing equipment so this
that you can see here is the rotter
sister that's that green thing on his
hip
and what that does is pull the the
weight
off the bottom of the the sea um
and also when you're pulling in a fish
it helps uh you bring it in a little bit
easier
so it's both for unskilled fishermen so
young people or
weaker people or it's for really skilled
fishermen that are out there all day and
they're getting fishing fatigue by
pulling in all day what's really cool
about it is
it's different to a gimbal which sits on
the front of you it doesn't hurt your
back
he has got himself a bunch of investment
he's just hit go on a bunch of family
and friends investment actually
he's just hit go on the first
run which is very exciting because he's
been talking about this for quite some
time and we helped him get the prototype
going for this we've also helped him do
digital marketing
website that sort of thing um yeah he's
exciting
and this is cam richardson he is a
fintech startup so financial tech
uh and this helps it's basically like
afterpay
if you've seen after pay but this is for
group buying
so when you go to buy a big wedding
present or
someone's 50th birthday present or a
21st prison or something like that
sometimes the gifts that you know they
want are a bit out of your your budget
but if you bring a whole bunch of people
together you can buy it together
what is different about this piece as
opposed to venmo or some of the other
consumer facing products this is
merchant facing
so it's all about making it easy for the
merchant to pinpoint when people want to
buy stuff together
and raise the value of the sale it's
quite cool
so he's had four term sheets uh put in
front of him in the last
three months and the whiplash of that is
quite outrageous so some of the work we
do is getting them investment ready as
well
and talking about investments we work
with otago and queenstown lakes
and have organized mainland angel
investors
which is a way of creating deal flow
between the three regions so we can put
our founders to angel invest investors
in each of the three regions
and they'll pitch to all three regions
on a little road tour
the good thing for our investors is they
get to see
due diligence from other regions so they
they get to jump on a syndicate with
others
but they also get to see other founders
coming into the region and
and be able to know what they're
supposed to expect i guess
um and the third part of coin is the
community events so
i truly believe that you can't be what
you can't see and in south and we don't
have a hell of a lot of alumni
uh we've got stabilicraft which is
awesome we've got backcountry we've got
a
we've got a handful um but they are
actually quite established businesses
now we don't have a lot in that next
like just above founder stage or that
one or two year mark
um so one of the biggest things is
making sure that we are bringing
people to the region that inspire
innovation
and startups so recently as part of our
prove it course we've brought down
roman from fix and fog
he is amazing he has the determination
of
a crazy man i think he makes peanut
butter if you haven't heard of fix and
fog
he's now selling to a thousand stores in
the states
which is pretty impressive and he's only
been going for six years
um anna from pledgeme just came down
last week
she started as the chief bubble blower
at pledgeme she is now on the board
there she has also
started a cheese cartel which is a
subscription cheese service that gets
that delivers cheese to your door and
she's just
exited that as well she's excellent work
um
what's really cool about anna is she
also has seen through pleach me
thousands of small businesses figure out
what who their crowd is and help them
get off the ground
and on the right is anton from flush or
hustle group
he started a fish and chip store in
wigram
just over the after covert sorry just
after the earthquakes
and has now got an events company and a
marketing company
and uh an apparel company i think i
think he's got seven businesses
um and he's just he came down to talk
about leveraging business after business
for the founders which was really quite
cool
also in the community i work really
closely with the young enterprise scheme
so i've had i mentor a lot
i think they'll probably go to my team
next year
but we we judge young enterprise we
sponsor young enterprise and what's
really cool is that 15 year old that i
talked about as the youngest founder
we've got came out of young enterprise
and they've got such a cool idea
that the engineers in south and are
really keen to get behind them
and help them get it off the ground
we've also had
the photo on the left is a group from
hargis
actually pitching with anna from
pledgeme and her taking them through
what they need to do in their pitch
which is pretty impressive
and we've had
dom who was in covert i mentored him
he pivoted his photography business
which is quite a simple business
into an online photography business so
he sold backgrounds for zooms
um throughout covert and made a lot of
money and won the invercargill
regional or southern regionals um to go
to wellington
we work really closely with southern
institute of technology they're
obviously a strategic partner but um
within that there's a group called the
flying kiwis who
are a group of mostly
colombian south americans who are really
interested in entrepreneurship
and keen to establish their own
entrepreneurship space within
sit so coins support that we took them
to startup weekend
in queenstown lakes which they won which
is exciting and then on the right hand
side we've got te
waka oahopai i think you guys call it
out here streets alive
perhaps yeah i know that's going great
um te waka oahopai we we did it a wee
bit differently we had co-design
workshops where we brought in a whole
bunch of people and i
facilitated design thinking methodology
to get the public
to come up with the ideas build on each
other's ideas
go out try some stuff and then do
another co-design workshop to build on
those things
so we ended up doing three of those we
did two events which we could validate
some of those ideas
and the pieces that are in macarthur are
really quite cool
i think it's exciting when engineers get
excited about bringing them to life
and they ask when the next project is
coming
through so we've got a tui that tweets
in the arcade in the chamber of commerce
um as you walk past it i think it
probably annoys them
more than it excites other people but
it's quite cool the engineers got really
excited about how to make it work
we've got these strange shelter boxes
that um i get to see from my window
which is quite nice so i get to see a
lot of people
using them and interacting with them but
yeah working with all the local
engineers around town to
kind of spread the love a bit we've
worked with 60
uh sorry 600 people and that's founders
and
events and our big hairy goal
is to make 10 southern businesses world
famous by 2026.
that comes off sir callahan's if we had
a hundred amazing kiwis
fixing new zealand uh it would be very
very simple i believe the same thing's
true in south and if we have ten of them
let's see
any questions
no thanks thanks for that uh luke um it
was very interesting uh particularly
having
prior to this being set up i actually
said on the advisory group when the
coin application went through for pgf so
it's interesting to see
some of the developments and how it's
actually progressed along for the last
couple of years but obviously the
report's there and i open it up to the
councillors or
um for any questions
yeah look you know congratulations it's
um
it's pretty exciting what's going on
around the place um
i'm just going to ask a question about
the um
the popcorn one um pitch yeah so how
many people just front up and
make a pitch uh it's really interesting
so the first one we had was in the
middle of covert
um so we had at the calvin and everyone
was spread out
two meters apart and it was quite
full-on but it actually
because everyone felt weird everyone was
on
a level playing field it's very informal
and i
somewhat bully people into pitching so
we got a huge amount of people i think
we ended up getting 36 or something
pitch in our first one and because of
the success of the first one
we had a lot turn up for the second one
um
i actually think the first one even
though we were spaced out was more fun
because it was weird so we'll take it
into consideration next time i think
how do you think we can help louise
um i think it's pretty obvious that or
not
maybe it's just obvious to me most of
our innovation isn't coming from
the cities necessarily it's it's coming
from the rural sectors and those
those food and fibre places and in the
engineering places so it's being
connected that's been our greatest asset
so far so if you know
anyone sharing uh that we exist and that
we are
certainly capable of helping out in gore
as well
but also connecting with the the other
sectors as well so
the engineers in invercargill have been
amazing in terms of prototyping help
um we lean on our accountants very
heavily
in a legal advice in invercargill so
it'd be awesome to see the same thing
happen out here
if you want to be a strategic partner
for us that would also be great
it's good to just be exposed to what's
going on um
probably most people in the room don't
really um haven't really had the
opportunity before so
i think we need to be sharing this wide
and far really
i think that's probably a big one as
well telling our stories is
so important because like i said you
can't be what you can't see if we all
share stories of innovation happening
other people get inspired and do it too
[Music]
through you mr chair um believed i was
one of those people that didn't know
um anything about what you're doing and
i think it's very exciting for southland
but i was wondering if if you if there
were barriers
to innovation that are happening and
could happen in gore
is there any specific thing like
resources or
lack of information i have a list
um i mean some of them are being broken
down
slowly so risk aversion is actually a
really big one
people are quite scared to say they're
going to give something new a try and so
they don't and that stops other people
from doing it and it's
self-perpetuating so that fear of
failure needs to be normalized and just
actually failure can be a good thing um
so that's a big one
seed funding is really hard and
because we've come from heritage where
we don't really ask for help it's really
hard to go out and ask our friends and
family hey would you back me for
five thousand dollars so i can at least
see if this is going to work
and there isn't really another option
other than friends and family right at
the beginning
you can pre-sell but you need to
validate your product before then so
um yeah if we had a seed fund of
a bunch of money that we could help show
that there's a way through that would be
awesome
kind of like the innovation fund um
alumni
we really need more people
showcasing how innovation is has helped
their business
um it's awesome having stabby and paul
adams down at home
um because he lives and breathes design
thinking
um but actually entrepreneur in
southland is quite a dirty word
as is investment so yeah
those those barriers are a bit hard but
we'll get there
we're only year two
many other questions here i'm aware
we've got some other presenters that are
sitting there so
um obviously if we have queries or
we have people who've got bundles of
money to invest in some of these um
great stars i do say we've got the
contacts there and it's probably one of
those things as the mayor said that
um it's out there and we need to be
pointing people in the right direction
because we do have these facilities that
come online in the last couple of years
and obviously
still developing and come along really
well there will be some stars in there
no doubt um thank you for your
presentation if i could just have some
uh move that that report's taken as read
uh councillor dixon and second it
councillor reed all those in favor aye
all right thank you so thank you very
much just a quick question
um mr chair so
um louise if you need to make contact or
want to make contact with us
do you have those all those details like
are you connecting with
with ann is
network business network so that that's
already happening
but it seemed when i asked a few people
they didn't know what coin was so
that's hence why lois has come here to
educate us
on what they're up to and we do run
really lean
so the more people in our corner that
can share our story
better and louise and the team are
working with businesses from gore
it's not just a local business i would
say probably
20 to this region this area of the
region
people were working with were just kind
of crazy
i guess it took me a wee while to get my
head around what coin was and it's
it's interesting that that's a name
that's been chosen
it doesn't make my life it doesn't make
my life easy no
no um people definitely come and ask if
we collect
coins and if we have a bank of money to
gift
to seed capital so
no thanks just sort of reaffirm what
in regard to anne's role there obviously
she is the conduit and you know
information coming and going
and the councillors are aware of you
know after this presentation
of what we've got there so yeah thanks
very much
our next agenda item there is
in regard to the neighborhood
support the establishment the
neighborhood support group there so
i think we hit
um kelly
kelly's there
um yeah we've got kelly how are you
kelly
good thank you
kelly just wants to get straight into it
so up to you
not sure everybody knows kelly maybe a
bit of an introduction
sorry kelly thank you mia
um yes everyone i'm kelly young i'm here
from the community networking trust
so i'm here to speak to you today about
neighborhood support um thank you very
much for having me
hopefully this will go very quickly
because i don't have senior sergeant
cynthia felia here in support today
she's in the north island
and comfortable julie russell who will
be my police liaison through this
project
is at firearms training today so it's
just me
should we just okay um so i put together
a
very brief presentation and susan sent
it out with the
agenda um it's pretty self-explanatory
so neighborhood support is community-led
movement that brings people and
neighborhoods together to create
safe resilient and connected communities
that fits
directly with the kaupapa of the
community networking trust itself
which i believe is why um senior
sergeant philly reached out to us to see
if we'd be interested in picking up this
project and launching it across eastern
southland
the aim is to assist neighborhoods and
communities to be safer
reduce crime be prepared for emergencies
which we as a community have all been
through plenty of
in recent times and increased community
connectedness and enhance well-being
which we all
again have been through during lockdown
as well so it's kind of a natural
progression out of lockdown we spent
all those weeks very excited to see
people from air safe distances and
bubbles um
we were all looking out for each other
keeping an eye on our neighbours
and then we kind of went back to our new
old normal
and a lot of that dissipated so we're
just looking to re
reinvigorate that and make sure that
we're all looking out for each other and
keeping the place a bit safer as well
so there's some information about what
neighbourhood support is
it's currently a national network of 69
member organisations of which
the community networking trust has
become one
we support over uh who support over 220
household
thousand households across aotearoa we
work
closely with new zealand police as
membership
as members of new neighbourhood support
we have a memorandum of understanding
with
the new zealand police uh so anyone
that's involved in the project of course
will police vetted to make sure that
they're safe
it is a community-led approach so the
beauty of neighbourhood support is while
they're
successfully doing it in multiple sites
across
the country we can tailor it to what our
community needs and that's
what we want to do as well provide
something that the community will uptake
and support
so it did put a little bit of a
slideshow in
the presentation but it's very simple
it's just what is community
support in terms of neighborhood support
how it works it's pretty simple
how i see it working and don't
necessarily quote me on this because
all things going well julie russell and
i will be attending the
bi-annual national hilly for
neighbourhood support in wellington on
monday morning
fingers crossed that we can still do
that so going to that hilly we will get
a better understanding of what the
project looks like in different
areas and then we can bring back that
kitty of knowledge and see what we can
launch here so we do
a little bit of a soft launch in this
room today just to let you know what's
going on
and see if we can work it together
[Music]
so then when we talked about it we see
it as going out into the communities
obviously she's got a really good reach
with him in rural policing as well why
julie's come on board too she reaches
out to tokunui she's based at wyndham
so we've got a good reach across there
getting it out into the small
communities i've already had
the tutorial community hall president
email me saying that they want to be a
part of it so we set up pockets we have
a database
uh we make sure that everyone's again
please fitted and
then the community takes it over you
know it might be a street representative
so there might be say for my example um
we might have a no my street
small community so air street will be
involved in neighborhood support we
might have a street leader someone that
liaises directly with me or julie or
whoever that's going to be
should it grow we can organise some
community events to promote it we can
have you know street barbecues things
like that just those
things that we did when i was a kid i
guess i grew up in a um
in a cul-de-sac and there was 30 odd
kids in our street
come five o'clock there was a mess
exodus as the dads all came home in the
cars so we didn't get run over but we
had barbecues we played cricket
everyone knew each other and it just
felt really safe like
i know things have changed a lot now but
we can still have some of those elements
of just knowing who your neighbours are
and checking in on them every now and
then
especially with our aging population
um we under neighbourhood support as
members we've got access to their
community resource kit which is fabulous
there's loads of print resources
stickers
eventually and with the council's
approval obviously
the neighbourhood support signs that go
up on the power poles to say this is a
neighbourhood support area
we will work in closely with the
existing community patrol
we've already had feedback from their
agm two weeks ago the police station
a good five or six members of that that
want to
cross the two projects together so that
we're all working
for the same course um
probably after that so the slideshow's
there
it's very basic there's stuff in there
about how to set it up
um the reason i put the slideshow in is
it talks about
how do you set it up so who's going to
set up your neighbors
neighborhood support groups the
community working trust will
we've got the resource and me
as the staff to run it at this stage
we've got the computer we'll make a
database
being a incorporated society as well we
are able to
manage the funds that come in with
neighbourhood support we can access
funding through them to provide
community events to go to hawaii and
to buy the resources the print material
and stuff that goes with it
so in terms of the starting the
connection and stuff we've already got a
lot of that infrastructure in place
just through our organization we've
already got a massive reach to get
connecting in with people so it it
seemed like a natural
place for it to sit with us
initially as i said in the report i will
be the primary contact
depending on what this thing looks like
and how it grows there is
resource available within that national
neighborhood support funding to actually
pay a coordinator if it needs to be
otherwise it's primarily voluntarily run
so we've got room to grow and scope to
move in there
where there is a full coat of conduct
that comes with neighborhood support so
it's
like i said all the infrastructure is
there it's just a matter of us kind of
working out feeling our way out a little
bit about what the community wants and
then
putting that stuff in place and
supporting it to keep growing and
connecting our community
that's really about it i came today not
asking for anything
[Laughter]
no that's just we just wanted to to let
local council know what we were doing um
there's a piece in there as well
which happened in the presentation that
comes directly from neighborhood support
how we can work together how it can
support local council
um as i said our kaupapa is about making
sure we've got a safe healthy and
resilient community and i know that
you've
the team wants to do that as well we're
all working for that same thing so
just alerting the council that this is
what we're hoping to roll out um
and at some stage we might be looking
for a little bit of support be that
putting some signs up on some
power poles be that maybe you know
some sheer communication to spread the
love a little bit
now i think um yeah i think clearly
probably it's the best uh
the best way is to have the report table
of this committee and then we work out
from there
where it goes back through to the um to
the main
council committee um around all whatever
aspect of this
a couple of things here obviously that's
the um we've had neighborhood watch
over the years i do remember having yeah
i remember having to
attend meetings as a constable in the
neighborhood watch groups in
invercargill
um and there's obviously databases and
various
old systems that are that are around
there but i think probably
um before i open up for questions if um
you know we look at it this committee
would love or the
main uh council would would like to
see probably a representative of this
group and the and the constables or
the sergeants to come along and present
what's actually happening in the area so
we know
so it's actually like a two-sided um
report we get an update on how the
neighbourhood supports going but also
the crime trend or what's happening in
our area so
because a lot of the matters that are
dealt with by council
um do associate to stuff that's
happening in the community
um and and they can all be linked in so
yeah
that's what sin was hoping to be here
today she was gathering up some steps
towards like rural and local burglary
right
the crime stats that reflect yeah yeah
which is hoping to be here but we can
get that data to you that's not a
problem which is the question that the
councillors will always
always want to know what's what's
actually happening in our community what
can we do
how can we help what are we missing and
and how can we apply
some change or direction in our thinking
to assist with those problems but um
thank you for that
kelly uh i'll open it up to the
councillors for any questions
venus ah thank you mr chair um kelly
good
presentation thank you i'm not good at
this this is not my forte at all
i'm wondering um are you going to be
working with the hakanui
on the system we will be yes we haven't
approached them yet because as i say
it's all kind of happened quite quickly
from the time that sun came and spoke to
robin and i about it initially
to sort of you know doing a membership
and
we knew the hulu was coming up but at
that stage
we'd been offered to apply to the fund
the operational funding and stuff for
that sort of stuff but we were oh maybe
it's a bit soon like we're not really
sure what we're going to do yet how this
is going to look
and it was actually neighborhood support
kelsey um she
just remember when it happened so fast
she emailed me one friday afternoon and
she said
one of their funders one of their
members had their funding approved
for the financial year and then for some
reason didn't need it anymore so she
sent me back an almost completed
application form on my behalf and said
can you sign this
and come to hawaii so it all happened a
bit quick and then you know working with
sin to find
a constable that was willing to liaise
with it so just building momentum
within our little what air team will
look like to start with before we put it
out there and then find out we haven't
got enough people on the ground to do it
within our team you know we just
bearing on the side of caution because
i'll be honest i've never done anything
like this before so i'm learning
very steep learning curve at the same
time but yes we will definitely be
working with locally wellness
thanks kelly on the uh presentation and
endorse what glenna says you're doing
well
um just a couple of questions i guess
you talked about tutorial being involved
do you see this being a rural focus as
well as an
urban focus i guess both um
one of the pitches that sin made which i
thought was brilliant and we are
intending to take to the field days as
well
is she envisions an entire map of
eastern southland and
you come along and you put your opinion
about where you live
and as people come into the tent and
then we see you know
have we got neighborhood support people
there can you connect in with them so
she will have a focus obviously
producing rural crime because we know
that the numbers are big um the
geographical location
the accessibility people have to going
into back sheds
haber and stuff like that so i think
it'll we want it to be
right across east and south and so
bridging that gap between rural and
urban
thanks and just picking up on what
richard was saying before
um you know he remembers neighborhood
watch from the past as do i
um and i'm just wondering this is a
slightly different name is that is the
name significant to what has been there
in the past i
i suspect it is now i wondered the same
and to be honest i haven't actually
found out
the answer to that i i wondered because
i when sinfer said about it i thought
immediately of neighborhood watch the
signs that used to be on the poles and
stuff
and i'm not i can't confirm whether this
has been a rebrand and a relaunch of
that product or if it's a completely
overhauled initiative that may have
superseded the old neighborhood watch
i can find that out i just don't know
sorry
i think we're we're pretty keen to be
involved so
yeah definitely i think we've um it's
part of
the long term strategy so is there any
other questions
from the floor therefore
thank you mr chair yeah it was a good
presentation thank you
um you're all very kind i'm just quite
keen i'm happy to hear that you're
working in with the community patrol
um and i'm also wondering like we've got
a lot of elderly who do live alone in
the community so support for them
apart from the crime thing as well i
mean a lot of them
live on their own and just that
neighborhood support that okay the
blinds aren't drawn this morning
do i ring on the doorbell and check
things like that and even sometimes like
when they've had operations and things
in surgery many don't have family
around and you know little things like
taking out their putting out their bins
and bringing them back in
would that be part of where you were
very much so we want to build those
mini communities within streets within
our larger community
and just have that stuff happening um i
remember cynthia saying in an
air sailing presentation last week they
during lockdown she's oh it's really
great because things were relatively
quiet she said the phones went off the
hook
with people being at home and just
noticing strange behaviors and calling
in
hey there's something really weird going
on so people were alert to that but now
that we've all kind of dissipated back
into our
old new normal it's not happening as
much so we want to get back to that but
it's exactly what you say counselor rate
is
you know jane down the streets just had
surgery i'm driving past
i see that a bin's not out it's red bin
day whip in knock knock
or just check your burnout jane just
that sort of stuff like just
pulling back a bit of their own business
i think and making a bit of time for
other people
great idea yeah very much so so we just
need to
have streets and then our communities
within those streets to
jump on board and yeah and i think it's
going to be a good thing too
for um new people coming into the
neighborhood or into the community as
well just a way to get to know people um
and also for like having been a
stay-at-home mom with little kids
it can get pretty isolating if you're
not out at group
type things but just a way to get to
know your neighbours and
yeah just it's that social isolation
hopefully this will be
an opportunity to reduce a bit of that
impact
thank you
any further questions here from floor
if i could just have someone move that
that report's taking the threat
council bulger and secretary
thank you kelly lovely thank you very
much for your time today you've done
well
thank you
the next agenda item is newcomers
network and we've obviously got mark
mccann
network coordinator and also our
community strength strategist manager
that's going to
talk to the report there so the floor is
yours for whoever wants to start
cool thank you hi everyone um
if i can firstly um give you an insight
into why this work is so important
um in terms of working with newcomers um
so we're about to install what we're
calling a welcome trail
in ghoul gardens and the goal main park
or opposite the school there
and this reflects the cultural diversity
of the district
we will have 40 different ethnicities
represented
on posts along that trail which is a
huge number
and would really surprise myself
actually
the census of 2018 from that the office
of ethnic communities recognized that
8.8 percent of the population
in the gore district were born overseas
compared to 27 percent nationwide
the stats new zealand website shows a
net migration of 14
000 people into new zealand from
overseas
prior to covid so i think we can uh
presume
that that number within the gold
district has increased since 2018.
um a survey at a high school that i did
this week showed that 49
of 431 students were
born overseas which accounts for 11 of
the school population
however that doesn't take into account
the international students that go there
as well
which judacovic is also a reduced number
of 11 that then accounts for 14 of the
population there
it's important to note as well that
newcomers are defined as
people who have also relocated from
different parts of new zealand to the
ghoul district
and it doesn't include people from wales
the uk the us canada or australia
so that number is likely to be far
higher than that
we could i guess presume that it's fast
approaching 20
of the gore district population and
rising
um we gave a report um a while ago
um a closing the gaps report where we
stated that 88
of businesses in the war district are
currently looking for someone or looking
to employ someone in the future
so we have an economy that's booming in
gold district
and we're hoping to attract more people
to work here so that number
again will presumably rise so we're
talking about a significant number of
the gold district population here
um if i can talk about welcoming
communities next so
we are well we were one of only nine
welcoming communities
councils within the whole country
this is a pilot scheme that was run um
and due to its success a number of other
councils have now come on board and i
think we're running now at 16 councils
so that's hugely exciting um part of
the um work that we do with welcoming
communities
which is an initiative and started up by
immigration new zealand
we have to put together a welcome plan
and i know uh bronwyn worked on the very
first
southland murihiku welcome plan and
dated three years ago
um which was a process that took i
believe you said two years
to put together um so this year
it's due to be updated um but after
feedback from wellington
immigration new zealand they've talked
uh about how we need to
scale back that plan um it was very
ambitious
and we also need to tailor it more to
the needs of the gore district itself
rather than southland wide which i think
is a fair comment
uh we're obviously a very different
community
compared to indocargo city council so
um we really want this plan to reflect
the voice of the nuclear
newcomer community um and to that
end we are going to hold a workshop
which anne has kindly offered to run
in the very near future we've invited
people from various communities um
ethnicities faith leaders
we're getting the voice of employees at
the council here
is this microphone okay that's good yeah
i'm not too close
um we've we've had the voice of um
employees at the council here
and we work very closely with the
international connect group which is
goal-based a multicultural and
multi-generational group to get their
ideas
so we're aiming to collect um
what their needs are what their
aspirations are
what possible opportunities they see for
themselves and to put those
all into a plan for them for the gore
district
that's where we're heading um
[Music]
a couple of initiatives that will be
reflected in that plan are as you can
see from the report um drive my life
um this initiative is
hopefully going to be funded and through
reap
um and we're waiting to hear anytime
soon i guess
as to whether that's going to go ahead
but the idea being that we are
going to support 30 newcomers southland
wide
10 from the court district to gain their
driver license at
whatever stage that is whether it be a
learner
and a restricted or a full license we've
discovered after discussions with the
police department
locally that southland actually has the
highest number of people
or migrants driving without licenses
in in the whole country so it's
something we're really really keen to
support
um the other thing is the leadership
academy
and this has been hugely successful
we've already had two people
graduate from the chamber of commerce
uh leadership academy which was held in
edendale
and uh we've carried out a quantitative
and qualitative survey of
the um the feedback from that course and
it was hugely hugely positive
and so that's really encouraging moving
forward we will have another two people
from the court district
take part in that course as well and
uh based again on the success of that
we're hoping to roll that over for
another 12 months
that's it
you've got anything to add to that or um
just maybe to let you know that the
workshop is planned for sunday the 11th
of july so it's coming up quite quickly
and by the time your next meeting in
september we'll have that plan to
present back to you
and probably just a touch base on the
driver's license
issue it's great that we've managed to
have some funding and mark and
has worked with the other councils but
this is also an issue under our closing
the gaps
and we have been in discussion with
other government agencies about how we
can
close this gap because for employers
and often young people especially
leaving school if they haven't got a
license
they can't get the job because they
can't get to work
and we're just in the process of working
with the high schools and surveying the
numbers and getting a handle on
how big an issue this is i saw some of
the first data i think there was one
person that had a full license in the
first round so there's some big gaps to
plug in that space as well
but it's not just with a good district
issue
when we talk to our colleagues around
other local authorities they're telling
us
similar stories so i just want you to be
aware that
there's an area there that we're trying
to do some work and see
what we can achieve
thanks sam um before we open that up for
any questions just
um obviously discussions around with the
community manager
strategic manager recently uh
in relation to some of these stats and
we actually look at it as a council
that um the diversity of the next
generation of
people that are going to be living in
the gore area is going to be so
different
and we need to incorporate that in the
decision-making
that the traditional generation of
people coming through is completely
changing
so um and we have to cater for that
so appreciate the work that's being done
now is probably going to be guiding us
for years to come
to make sure that we're keeping
ourselves in line with what our actual
community is being
represented as so but uh open that up to
the floor for
any questions for mark or anne in
relation to that
well just a couple of comments um mr
chair um i just want to congratulate
mark on the work that he's doing he's
obviously
getting out there and about and and
doing some really good
um stuff in terms of programs but also
making some huge connections and
that's pretty important for us going
forward
it seems like just yesterday that we had
our first newcomers
network function which was a
multicultural fest
and everybody was astounded in
celebrating the fact that we had 27
different
ethnicities represented there now to see
that coming up to 40
in a very short time really does reflect
the trend that we're going to see more
and more of and
you've only got to look at the employees
that we have at our own council
right the you know the percentage here
is quite quite high now
um so that's reflected right across the
country so well done
thank you mr chair um yeah i'd like to
congratulate you mark i think it's
really good to have thin down that focus
and make it more gore-centric um for the
people that we have in our community
um usually through the churches and the
schools we do
manage to assimilate a lot of those
people in
and i know mahala when she was you know
she did a wonderful job
but it would be really um i think it
really behooves us to
be able to work with the people find out
what
their first impressions were how much
help they had to move into the community
and where did that help come from
which part of the community because i
sometimes think
employers bring people in and we just
are brilliant they're at work
get on with it and you know and there's
a lot of things that
we just take for granted because we know
how the
area works so i'd like to see you know
i know that you will work along those
lines absolutely if i can just respond
to that and
only last friday renasa and myself met a
couple
that are looking to move to the core
district and the husband is looking to
work with
tower valley milk and his wife um is a
doctor
and um matara valley milk asked us to um
talk with them talk about the gall
district and how great it is to live
here and what's available to them in
terms of
newcomer support um we sounded like
secondhand car salesman but
i think we did a great job and it looks
like they may end up coming down here so
that's
really encouraging working with those
companies to make that happen
yeah which i guess takes us on to
another challenge about where they're
going to live when they come here yes
yeah yeah
okay any more questions or
on the floor look i'm happy to move the
receipt
of the report and second council or
bulger
all those in favor thanks mark thank you
to our next agenda item is our events
report association awards we just um do
we have someone presenting
thank you through the chair i think it's
quite self-explanatory
i suppose the purpose is really just to
show the counselors
what we've achieved in the year past and
it's not until you enter these things
and actually start to write down
everything that you've done
that you realize that wow we did
actually achieve something pretty
special
um with with limited resources so
we'll find out um next month whether
we've made the cut or not um
i'm pretty sure we will i'm quite
optimistic and yeah we'll go from there
but um i'm happy to take any questions
thanks sonia yes it's actually very
refreshing to read
some of the commentary in here
particularly in relation to
some of the recent commentary that
councils received this is actually some
really uh really positive um positive
commentary around um
the uh the hunt and the different things
like that it was um
i think uh you know people should take
time to look at some of these great
things that are actually happening out
there and
for kids and and those positive things
that are in there in a great community
out there
sometimes we get stuck with some of the
um the hard stuff
but it's good to see the good stuff and
uh particularly when it's been reflected
and
putting us forward for these awards so
any
questions from the floor or commentary
bromwood thank you mr chair just a
comment um i know
last year after the community awards
that everybody that went and there were
an awful lot of people who went
and i think the fact that we had a at a
cheaper
price made a difference for a lot of
people but they were just
blown away they did not know what we did
as a council for the community as far as
supporting our volunteers and
sports peoples and people like that in
the community
there was a real buzz and a real vibe
after that event
which i've never heard or seen before so
i
thought it was a really good public
event
to hold and just have a positive outlook
i completely agree just if i might add i
suppose um
events like that and other events that
we hold do have a really positive
spin-off for the council and as you
quite rightly point out mr chairman
um you know it does create a good vibe
in the community and it
is good reputation-wise for the council
too to be involved in these sort of
things
yeah just add to those those same
comments and congratulate
everybody that's been involved and
getting to the point we are now
because i know there's been an awful lot
of work going behind the scenes that
probably never ever gets
seen or appreciated so so to everyone
that's been involved well done
and i guess there's only one downside in
getting to this sort of level that
you've got to
surpass it next time so um good luck
happy to move the receipt mr chair if
you're only a second are there
councillor davis all those in favor say
okay we move on to our next item on the
agenda which is
uh um confirm this
under yes ready for living our progress
report in regards to ready for living
i think we have kylie here who's going
to come along and
give us an update on how we're going
so the floor is yours kylie and
give us a bit of an update and then
we'll ask some questions or
be satisfied at the end cool
um cure dakota everyone um i'm kylie
mostia's know me i've been working on
ready for living for
over a year now um so
i don't know how much you know really
for living was developed
through the tracy knows more than me um
through the council
in 2018 um so the feasibility report
came was developed and so we're tracking
for a
third of the population in gore is going
to be over 65
by 2038 so
the whole project's focused around their
initiatives to make sure gore is
the good place for older people to live
and then saying that it's about
um if it's a good place for older people
it will suit everyone
in the community so um
my role as coordinator for the yet first
last year has been quite um
varied i guess um we started some
exercise classes up they were lacking in
goal for the older population
um so they're credit accredited now
um and have about 20 people coming
weekly so this
class is maxed out so i'm looking for
another class someone to take another
class um
been meeting with lots of groups in the
community so
every senior citizens lions
support link morning teas going around
lots of old people's groups telling them
what is available lots of people don't
know what's available in the community
and talking about what i do
and then courses and things that are
popping up that seem to have gone under
the table so lots of the community
didn't know about things happening
especially with their age missing out on
social media
and stuff so just making sure everyone's
aware of
things coming up being involved with
computing classes for older people
a driver's license course for seniors
i've been quite involved with hakanui
runanga so um
going to the komator days and working in
along them and promoting their
free nursery clinic which most of the
community don't know about that it's
open to everyone um
advocating through different groups
streets alive
helped talk to lorraine about the
library and how to better
fit um older people and making sure
um things were considered from doors to
seating
higher seating and sign colours and
different things that have came through
manuals
and so that's been quite good
um we've got
through cali and community connections
we've got a total mobility contract now
so that's half price taxis
so you council pay for that and i don't
know someone i was talking to didn't
know much about that
so total mobility is run by the three
councils
steve's nodding steve knows the three
councils
um and why we have there's a few people
in gore that have the membership
i think a couple of hundred i think the
man said um
but they're not using it much so it's
that 50 off taxis
they're assessed for people that can't
um
drive or they say access a bus
is how um that works so um
of course and community networking trust
have got that to help make it easier for
people to get that
um we've been working on our website
updating it because it's done all about
the feasibility
that's taking a bit of time up um
helping out with the gore directory so
all the services
um clubs organizations we're trying to
get them online in a
document so that's been happening
um age-friendly business i see tracy's
got his book out
on that so a truly business was quite a
big initiative just as i started um we
got a contract from office for seniors
to be a pilot for age-friendly business
um we had a consultant jeff pearman come
down for this
um and we had seven workshops uh
seven focus groups and two workshops
richard was involved and i think
doug was involved from council as well
and tracy you
you were there sometimes yeah
met jeff a couple of times um so this is
about businesses becoming more aware of
what older people need and that there is
a growing demographic
um in being focused so
we haven't had that good uptake from
school businesses but it's going to be
a push um going forward so i think i've
got seven businesses
on board that were all for it and
understand the whole concept so
that's good and it has become an
international recognition now
um international national sorry um so
office for seniors have a program
um throughout the country for this um
and it's about me i think my
action plan was attached the new one was
it in yeah yeah
so just um this is really following on
from last meeting when we met with
um community strategy committee so
kylie and i have done a bit of work in
looking at everything that had been
previous
and pulling the action plan which is
that that document there which is really
the work
going forward so things that have been
completed have been removed things that
um
work in groups that have had been here
before so we've pulled everything
in there to make it current so that
would set the work going forward
we have uh put a funding application to
ph bakery trust which
would have been heard yesterday so we
expect to hear the outcome of
that because ph vickery trust have been
the funder of kylie's position
so the plan at this stage is if we're
successful with that money
um that cody's position will continue
and she will be
based here at the council so we're just
waiting to hear
um so we haven't that's one of the
reasons we haven't pushed the
business friendly yet we wanted to make
sure that we had all the ducks in a row
before we
launch with that project in any big way
yeah
okay thanks um kylie obviously uh
the it's still interesting to drill down
into some of those topics and
and how we're going it'd be interesting
to uh
if we can get reported back on in
relation
to the age-friendly business um update
particularly some of the changes we've
had in the cbd
like with the streets live and how
that's linked in
um to see where being involved in those
workshops it was very interesting just
things that i didn't even consider when
i was walking through a shop that i'd
knocked something off a shelf or
wouldn't go into a shop because of that
sort of behaviour or that sort of action
um it was little things that came out
you realize that uh
there's a a clear connection between
your business and actually the person
that walks through the door and how
they're going to
actually action themselves in your shop
so it's been
a learning process i think for a lot of
people within the community but
um i'll open it up for the any questions
or discussion from
councillors
i just want to again congratulate um
kylie on on the work that she's doing
it's been a challenging year on a number
of fronts
um and hopefully we um we are successful
with our funding and we can put it on a
firm footing to
to go forward because there is some real
value for this community to be
uh to be working in the in this space
and just touching on the age for energy
business
in the case for change that is in your
agendas there
i just can't get over the the spend
change that's likely to happen
by people who are over 65 going into the
future so
we as a community but particularly we as
a business community have got to be much
more attuned to
what older people uh expect and will pay
for
uh than we have been in the past and
even the life expectancy
looking between 200 1966 and 2016.
it's stretching out quite quite
dramatically
and for someone that's in probably in
that age group it's good to see it
stretching out even further
um but look congratulations something
you did mention on the way through their
colleague and possibly most counsellors
or a lot of counselors aren't aware of
what goes on around kamato a day
and the green prescriptions you just
want to give a bit of insight into
what the renault are doing and what
we've been involved with there
um so the commercial day is run
for the so kamato is um older maori
people that are respected
so there's no age limit um so that
is around every three weeks and it's a
health day for them so they
often have a speaker first so how heart
foundation civil defense came up the
other week um
they had blood pressure checks and
different things so that's every three
weeks and they have a meal with that
and i feel they might be they get
funding through maybe dhb
don't quote me on that um for that um
there is funding that they have or it
might be through
naitahu to specifically focus on the
older people in their house for that
um the other one is the free nursery
clinic so
once or twice a month um they have a
nursery clinic in goa
at the roonanga and once
in between times they have it in matera
so that's every yeah in between so
that's free for anyone to um
go to um services run that i believe
um the health service so that's not very
specific that's anything
so anyone's allowed to go um so
yeah there was need for another one they
thought but there is space at that one
in their initial action plan
um
oh thank you mr chair um kylie yes good
report
just wondering um there's quite a few
incentives through the gold card
that a lot of elderly people aren't
aware of
when they're buying product i just
wonder if you have done any work
so i have made a list it's on a website
and i have a folder i take everywhere
with me
of course providers but a lot
aren't available in gore there was quite
a um small
group in gore so um but
yeah yeah there are a number there yeah
um
one thing i would have to say different
times when i've looked at that website
or on their facebook
it's um it's not the easiest one to use
uh it's not that user-friendly i'd have
to say which is a bit of a shame and
and i know it's been updated but from my
perspective it
probably has got a bit to go here
yeah i think the grey power card is used
more often
than that thing and grey power
are looking at folding um at the moment
yeah it's interesting that um
grey power are really struggling and yet
the age group
that they service is growing
dramatically they do have
800 members or over 800 members getting
the discount but not attending
that committee meetings the difference
yeah that probably
reflects where people's interests lie
everywhere isn't it
thanks mr chair um i just wondered
whether you're talking about the
nurse-led clinics and that's available
to anybody
how would you go or are you is that
being advertised
um to an extent i think it comes out of
the community networking trust that um
things come out i do when i'm out and
about i always have that flyer in there
too
um doing it so have they done anything
about advertising it right through
the inside or on the radio things like
that i think i've seen it through there
but then it's that there's supply demand
as well
yeah it might be more than one nurse
maybe but i think it's actually a lot of
people
really struggle having to go to the
doctor and pay big prices so
i just maybe it's something you could
look at
yes not my organization but i can talk
to them about it
well yeah please yeah and i was just
going to say you've obviously been
exceptionally busy
um ann are you doing all those meetings
as well
no i'm not from
our fabulous coordinator but i've been
looking at all the strategic side of it
and how we're going to
go forward and it's been more my role in
this and working with
cali yeah it's certainly shaping up
quite nicely
yeah we just need to get the funding is
what we're hanging out for now
thank you
okay so we've had that report presented
and obviously
uh if we actually look at the last three
gender items the three presentations we
have
they're actually all linked and as we
say about funding it's hard to put a
dollar value
on the safety and well-being and actual
activity of the individual in the
community so
um and all three of those newcomers the
police
neighborhood support and um their
current one the age
age reports so could i have someone who
would like to that's received
council read in a second uh councillor
dixon
all those in favor okay
uh that moves on to the final january
item there which is actually linked in
again
to our um if i find it
i think it's worth world health
organization
um accreditation so
uh are you presenting that man okay
has received recognition under the world
health organization as an age-friendly
cities and communities
and probably one of the biggest benefits
for us of being part of this is the
resources
that are being made available to us and
already i think mayor said on one
zoom meeting and so have i from the
world health organisation in the middle
of the night
but it was very fascinating and a lot of
valuable information
for our community that we can use i'm
just doing a quick look at the stats i
think i came
when i looked at um the last synthesis
we had about 42 of our populations over
50.
so kylie was quoting the 65
over 65. so this is actually really
significant if you take on board
marks comments about newcomers and then
you take your elderly population or the
aging community these are two
significant areas of our community when
we start talking community strategy
so i think one of the big benefits for
us with this
is actually giving us access to a lot of
resource
and other people that are working in the
space and grappling with
what it means to have an aging community
the only other community correct i think
kylie is hamilton that has this
recognition
um in new zealand at the moment so
college you want to make some comments
neither of us were involved in putting
this application together
it was it was done prior both of our
time
so yeah
it's just awesome to have it finally um
it's been on the cards for a wee bit
um and took a while to get
but it is a lot of what we had in our
action plan
um there are guidelines that suggest
other ideas too
um which are awesome to have a look at
and work towards
um it's a lot about sharing experiences
and achievements and
sharing what's happening in other areas
so you can find out
and go copy or replicate in your own way
um
good things that are coming up so
yeah and it's about the community
contributing to so it's not
just about us leading but getting their
input and seeing what they think are
um issues or um positives in the
community and working from there
yeah yeah
thanks ann and kylie yes yeah obviously
congratulations and it probably is a
congratulations to the community
i think that gore generally in my short
time on council
the senior members of the community that
are out there
are well recognised and they are they're
not um
not shelved they are taken notice of and
they um they also
are very very active and certain
occasions involved in our community and
the way it's run
and the way we go about our daily
business both in the business world
and also just in their um day-to-day
lives so i think it's a credit um we'd
be interesting to see where it goes and
what develops out of this
you know what we're going to achieve
from it and recognition and
as you say what other resources or
opportunities arise so
but i open that up to the counsellors
for anyone to
have any questions or discussion
i don't really have any questions mr
chair but just um just congratulations
to um
kylie and and for the way that they've
picked this program up and
they've really given it some focus over
the last little while
there's a huge potential for change and
benefit for our community in this space
i think
and you know most of us haven't really
got our heads around just
the scale and the scope of that
and ann mentioned that we did sit in on
a
zoom meeting unfortunately their zoom
meetings are in start about 1 30 in the
morning
but it was really fascinating to get
some perspective from
africa and uh various parts of
uh europe uh north america uh and asia
and
in some of the challenges those people
are having and you know where
um it does did reinforce to me that
we're in a pretty good space
but there is a lot we can learn from
them as well
so well done congratulations and fingers
crossed for some funding
yes and it's probably worth just
mentioning that shelly
lithgow who also has been involved along
this process and and um you know the
situations
changed and she put a lot of hard work
in there so
yeah i think she should be recognized
amongst that working working group as
well so
absolutely it was really shelley's
initiative to go down this track of um
age friendly recognition and we had no
idea whether it would be successful or
not
we had no idea how many people how many
communities in new zealand
had taken it up along the way and i'm
i'm a little bit surprised and possibly
a bit disappointed that there's only two
so it's good to see us in the vanguard
of what's going on
there's no further discussion there i'll
just seek someone to
have their report received happy to move
uh the receipt of the report
and secondary
council dixon all those in
thank you that's the end of our agenda
a bit of a good discussion and uh
interesting topics and agenda there that
have linked in quite nicely so
um so it's if there's nothing further
there we have no late items so i'll call
the meeting tour
yeah i guess i'm um tell me if i'm out
of order
um but just a couple of things that i
think we need
as a community strategy committee to
consider
into the future and i think we need to
get our heads around
what the health reforms are likely to
look like in this part of the world what
the effect of those might be
and what part we might play in those
going forward so
possibly and i haven't talked to hannah
about this sorry but possibly at the
next
community strategy meeting uh if we can
have
uh some insight into that and maybe uh
somebody from
that health sector who might be able to
give us
some on the ground perspective and also
in
recent times the concern around
mental health and availability for
mental health
help in the community has been very much
a focus on every news building you hear
um
and you know part of a a zoom meeting
this morning getting a bit of a heads up
on what's happening in this part of the
world
and i think it's pretty important that
we as a council
understand some of the challenges that
that locally we're facing
and we may be able to have some input on
the national perspective so
i think that the general physical or
that general health
restructure and where mental health sits
in this community particularly would be
good
yeah for some time in the future we can
um put that into our
put that on our on our table or on our
radar
um the mental health one i think is
particularly around the community
community well-being
um and also there's the lincoln
uh obviously our safer communities that
that
new network is working on it would be
interesting to see the link
you know through the community support
that's actually happening
clearly it has hit the headlines and
it's not um it doesn't actually look
very good that
the money that's actually been injected
in there it'd be interesting to know
what we've actually had
given to us locally if anything so
that's right
if there's nothing else from the floor
i'll close the meeting
thank you for your attendance councils
thank you
you